when battled Virginia Governor Ralph
Northam is resisting calls to resign
over a racist photo in his medical
school yearbook Northam at first
apologize for the 1984 photo which shows
one man dressed as a KKK member in
another and what appears to be blackface
but over the weekend the Democrat
changed course and said he's not in the
photo Northam explained that he had made
a similar mistake in the same year the
racist yearbook photo was taken I did
participate in a dance contest in San
Antonio in which I dark in my face is
part of a Michael Jackson costume I look
back now and regret that I did not
understand the harmful legacy of an
action like that ed O'Keefe it's outside
the governor's mansion in Richmond
Virginia ad the governor is getting
calls to step down from both sides
he sure is but he back pedaled on
Saturday saying he's not going anywhere
after consulting with his family his
pastor and some of his former classmates
last night he met with senior aides just
here at the mansion made increasing
calls for his resignation but there's
been no new announcement from him
leaders on both sides of the aisle are
calling for him to resign including
several 2020 Democratic presidential
contenders and both of Virginia's
Democratic US senators president Trump
even called his actions unforgivable one
senior Democratic state senator told us
last night that because of his quote
dark secrets Northam has lost the
confidence of fellow Democrats if he
steps down the state's lieutenant
governor 39 year-old Justin Fairfax
would step in becoming the nation's
youngest and only black governor
currently we Democrats are expected to
meet today once again to see if there's
any way to force him out at that
incredibly awkward news conference on
Saturday we asked Northam when he might
realize he can no longer effectively
lead Virginia he said quote we'll take
it one day at a time
Nora will be watching it thank you I
mean awkward was the word for that news
conference I couldn't believe when he
was asked about moonwalking looked like
he was about to do it until his wife
stepped in and said nope maybe that's
not a good idea good thing he was there